- Hey, come on in.
(bouncy keyboard music)
Yes, push and
believe, you got it.
I'm here with Dan.
Y'know Comedy Central said,
'you can't do an
interview from bed,
'you gotta be in a table,'
I go, 'I'm Steven
Brody Stevens.'
- Yeah.
- I've got a half hour special,
if I wanna do an interview
in bed with a friend
we do it right here.
- And y'know what, I like this,
this is much more comfortable.
- So Dan, we're here in Boston,
we're here in a
great hotel room,
I put it down on my debit card,
incidentals, everything's
taken care of.
I do have doughnuts here
from a local establishment
if you would like, these
are some options here,
we have chocolate.
- I'm gonna go with this one
'cause it looks
like it might have.
- Tasty.
- I think it tasted better
'cause you fed it to me.
Can I feed you one?
- I like chocolate.
- You like chocolate?
- I like chocolate, here
we go, now go slow with me.
You did the whole thing at
once, I'm gonna nibble and chew.
- You're gonna nibble and chew?
Alright y'ready?
Slow, just take, oh that was
much more sensual than my bite.
- A little more.
- Lemme rearrange it,
okay now, no, now you're
just kissing it, no, bite it.
Okay you're gonna bite my,
I'm just gonna let the
whole thing go, no, okay.
- Save that for later.
How tall are you?
- I'm 6'4, how tall are you?
- Six two.
- Are you good at basketball?
- I played basketball
in high school,
I'm not in to it
so much any more,
I'm more in to kettle bells,
I'm in to public park workouts,
I mean can you dunk?
- No, I'm not good
at basketball.
- 'cause you're white.
- Yeah, also 'cause
I'm scared of uh.
- Of black people?
- Yes.
- You do a lot of
hosting, I'm a host.
Y'know we can both close shows,
obviously we're doing half
hours, we're in Boston,
they wouldn't bring us out
here if we were only hosts.
- Let's lean up for this,
'cause I feel like we're
gonna get in to it.
- What skills does
it take to be a host?
I think there's a lot
of comedians out here
who think when you host you
just get up and tell your jokes
and you get out of there.
You go outside,
you have a drink,
you have a little
hit off a joint, no.
- You're working.
- You're working, you're
literally working.
- All the time.
- And that's why
the host gets more money
than the headliner.
- 'cause they're supposed to.
- I've had anger
issues in the past.
- You did?
- Oh yeah.
- Really?
- I front kicked a guy
in a 7-11 parking lot,
I flipped out at
the Comedy Store,
I went off my meds cold turkey,
and now I'm choking Dan!
- Hey, hey, there
he is, there he is.
You doin' alright bud?
- You know what calms me down?
- What calms you down?
- I have an app,
y'know applications.
- You have your own
app for your phone?
- Yeah, check it out.
I perform at all, I perform,
I perform, I perform.
- You're like the
Skrillex of comedians.
(techno music)
- Lemme see this.
- Give it a shot,
have fun with it,
it's gonna make you feel better.
- I could throw
eighty-eight with movement.
Eighty-eight with
movement, that's baseball,
y'know I played baseball
at Arizona State.
- Did you really?
You're a D1 athlete?
- Play a little
catch, here we go.
One, you got it, try it again.
Right handed, throw.
- Y'know this is
the closest I've had
to having a catch with a dad
since I was five years old.
This kinda means a lot to me.
- Y'know my father passed away,
it was either in 1996 or 2005,
and I would play catch
with my father growing up
and this kinda reminds me.
Dan I am so happy and pleased
that you came into my room.
- Of course.
- And I'm gettin'
tired right now,
I'm gonna take a
quick power nap,
be comfortable, make
yourself at home,
if you could wake me up
in about 20, 25 minutes,
I have to go down
to Dunkin' Donuts.
- Hit it hard buddy.
- You got it, Dan Sodor.
Yes, what a great video,
it's inspired me to exercise,
it should inspire you
to click, and subscribe,
and like, and even tweet at me.
Whoo, feelin' good,
laughter makes me exercise
yes, you got it,
push and believe.